[Musica]
[Applauso]
io voglio parlarvi della bellezza dalla
bellezza dei dati dell'intelligenza
artificiale e di un cambiamento il
cambiamento di cui vorrei che non
avessimo paura la scienza dei dati e ci
permette di osservare fenomeni complessi
della società e della e della natura con
una specie di microscopio nuovo che
fatto da due parti
i dati che sono poi le tracce digitali
possono essere tracce digitali che noi
stessi che le persone lasciano
nell'utilizzo dei tanti servi servizi
informatici che abbiamo a disposizione
dagli scontrini della spesa fino ai
telefoni cellulari dai nostri accessi a
internet o quant'altro
i sensori sensore che sono ora così
miniaturizzati che possono essere
utilizzate nei contesti più svariati dai
dispositivi personali fino all'orto di
casa e poi l'altra componente gli
algoritmi gli algoritmi che ci permette
di andare a caccia algoritmi i metodi di
natura statistica matematica fisica che
ci permettono di andare a caccia su quei
tanti di di cose da imparare
noi la chiamiamo scoperta scoperta di
conoscenza
allora si possono osservando gli
spostamenti gli spostamenti delle
persone che attraverso i dati dei loro
telefoni cellulari si può si può capire
come una città un territorio è vissuto
come dove le persone vanno vengono si
fermano qua tutto si fermano ed è facile
immaginare quanto chiaramente questa
informazione possa essere utile per chi
deve progettare ad esempio trasporti
pubblici o comunque le risorse di un
territorio di una città dove la mobilità
a un elemento fondamentale ma anche e
tutti siamo in continuazione quanto è
utile per noi per capire qual è il
percorso migliore per andare da da un
posto da un posto ad un altro
oppure dai carrelli della spesa dalle i
nostri scontri nip entrate si può
studiare e qual è il livello di
diffusione di un influenza stagionale
oppure capire capire qual è il livello
di integrazione di gruppi di immigrati
categoria e ripetibili persone che hanno
cambiato il loro il loro paese di
origine
dai dati genomici dei pazienti possiamo
imparare le relazioni che possono
esserci tra le diverse malattie e magari
capire capire se ci sono possibili cause
comuni dalle diagnosi fatte dai medici
messe messe a comune si può imparare a
distinguere sulle immagini
quali sono le caratteristiche benigni e
maligni ad esempio di un neo e quindi
costruire degli strumenti che servono di
supporto ai di supporto ai medici per
nuove diagnosi e quindi in questo questo
caso dice abbiamo sistemi predittivi che
aiutano e una persona a a migliorare il
loro processo decisionale perchè hanno a
disposizione anche l'informazione
ulteriore informazione questo tutto
questo si chiama data suns e scienza dei
dati e alla base guardate della medicina
personalizzata dell'agricoltura di
precisione scienza museale scienza
scienze sociali cioè potrei continuare
davvero c'è una trasformazione in corso
di tutte di tutte le discipline e fare
questo mestiere di fatto significa da
una parte avere il possesso di queste
tecnologie
la manualità di queste tecnologie e poi
lavorare a fianco di i medici agronomi
economisti capire qual è il problema che
potrebbe essere migliorato e poi
immaginarsi i quali dati utilizzare
quali sistemi analitici e mettere e
mette a disposizione quindi per
migliorare e risolvere quel problema e
guardate il momento in cui stiamo
vivendo è stata questa dimensione
digitale della società in cui davvero la
scienza le date l'intelligenza speciale
anno hanno un contributo un contributo
fondamentale
stiamo vivendo una grande trasformazione
e chi ora sta utilizzando queste
tecnologie di fatto sta sta progettando
un po la società del futuro e non è
possibile che ci siano così poche
ragazze a dire la loro
questo è questo guardata bene
soprattutto nel mondo occidentale nel
mondo occidentale e ci sono pochissime
ragazze che accedono ai percorsi i
percorsi stemmi quelle appunto
matematica fisica informatica ingegneria
è così come se il percorso
computazionale ci fosse distante che
pure alla prima programma tv c'era una
donna
sicuramente ne avete sentito parlare
la dallo plus che nel 1843 fu quella che
codifica il primo algoritmo che faceva
calcolare un numero di bernoulli ad un
calcolatore al primo prototipo
calcolatore che si chiamava che si
chiamava appunto analitiche il gene che
aveva fatto un suo amico era charles
burbage e poi le le programmatici pensa
tutto il programma apollo da 11 12 13 e
tutte le traiettorie venivano calcolate
da un team di matematica e di colore
guidate da guidate da carte da catherine
johnson che è appunto che erano a
scienziate e scienziati di eccellenza
affidabilissime che appunto su cui
venivano poi ricostruite tutte le
traiettorie dei vari apollo un film
molto carino fatto nel 1000 2000 e 16
che si chiama il diritto di contare che
che racconta appunto con questa storia
che è anche una storia di segregazione
razziale
però appunto è carino vedere come come
di fatto è anche una non sono i
progressi della società in tutte le sue
dimensioni
quando io mi sono iscritta alla fine
degli anni settanta c'erano le ragazze
non erano quasi metà degli uomini nei
corsi di informatica soprattutto il
corso di informatica perché era vista
una cosa una cosa nuova era avevamo la
percezione che il mondo del computer e
allora stesse costruendo il futuro
ora le ragazze sono meno attratte da da
queste discipline perché la vedo un po
come discipline da nerd non è perché le
ritengono difficili perché le ragazze
poi sono hanno buone performance però è
perché appunto
secondo me la ritengono noiosa o
perlomeno è come se non ci fosse più
niente interessante se avesse se fosse
già stato tutto stato stato già definito
e invece e invece no ecco io credo che
oggi proprio appunto grazie a questa e
tecniche di riceva la data stein se
l'intelligenza speciale e si sta
progettando un futuro nuovo una società
nuova
il problema è che questa società può
andare in direzioni diverse può andare
nella direzione ad esempio che del
monopolismo che ci sia l'accumulo delle
tecnologie nella mani di pochi
oppure può andare una direzione che
appunto si accetti il fatto che si
rimpiazzino le persone ecco è che qui
c'è il momento di rappresentare nella
progettazione di questo di questo futuro
che ci sia rappresentata è quella che è
la diversità della società e le donne
sono una componente importante non
possono non possono non esserci e ci
sono tantissime cose ancora ancora da
appunto ad accompagnare in questa
direzione che vogliamo fare di una
società che può essere sì supportata
dalla tecnologia non una tecnologia per
la tecnologia ma una società che usa
quella tecnologia quindi una tecnologia
che ad esempio stimola stimola le
persone con cui
a ragionare non invece fa le fa delegare
all'algoritmo quindi demandare demandare
e ridurre la propria capacità anche no
di agire oppure rimandiamo alla
piattaforma che ci suggerisce il link da
seguire senza neanche osservare poi le
conseguenze di questa cosa
oppure che si genera discriminazioni
discriminazione dei deboli è di persone
fragili o semplicemente conformismo e
poi ci sarà un grandissimo bisogno
massimo bisogno di di aumentare la
consapevolezza di queste tecnologie
affinché proprio come dicevo crea queste
diventi non ha il potere il potere di
pochi rimangano nelle mani di pochi non
dobbiamo andare in una tecnocrazia
guardate in questo momento proprio
perché la maturità la maturità e la
potenzialità di impattare la società che
hanno queste tecnologie è come se
fossimo al punto immaginato d'animo nel
64 lui scrive un'introduzione ad una
nuova ad una raccolta di vecchi racconti
che loro ha scritto nei 20 anni
precedenti allora fa un po una
riflessione su su questo mondo di robot
che lui si era immaginata noi tutti
questi racconti e riflettere anche sui
rischi delle società di robot di robot e
umani dell'interazione tra robot umano e
che lui aveva immaginato non è
effettivamente vittima mente potrebbe
essere anche tutta questa conoscenza
possa anche avere dei rischi per la
società però poi si rassicura se
rassicura dicendo è però noi siamo stati
capaci di importante sono state tante
invenzioni che avevano dei rischi però
siamo stati capaci poi di per così dire
metterle in sicurezza per ben essere al
servizio del nostro perciò abbiamo messo
le guaine ai fili elettrici il manico al
coltello la ringhiera alle scale quindi
se noi concentriamo non la nostra
energia
mettere in sicurezza a mettere al
servizio queste tecnologie al servizio
della società che vorremmo magari una
società più giusta una società che
rispettosa dell'ambiente
ecco se possiamo farlo se ci mettiamo
tutta l'energia necessaria e quindi è
questo il momento di immaginare questa
intelligenza artificiale che sia che
vada in quella direzione della direzione
che sia di un futuro che sia benefico
alla persona la società e non possono
non esserci le ragazze quindi allora il
messaggio dove saggio davvero senza
paura di non essere adeguate senza paura
di fallire senza paura della matematica
senza paura di diventare dei nerd degli
esseri sociali e anche senza paura di
rovesciare gli assunti di quella di
quella tecnologia di oggi perché noi
possiamo fare se ce la mettiamo
l'energia